on va parler de la grande oubliée de
cette campagne présidentielle la
question climatique a fait l'objet d'un
nouveau rapport du giec lundi médias et
politiques confondues presque personne
n'en a parlé des scientifiques du giec
font pourtant des propositions concrètes
pour agir dès maintenant samia de chiens
trois ans pour inverser la tendance si
l'on veut limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degrés les émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre
doivent commencer à baisser d'ici 2025
il faut donc agir dès maintenant
l'avertissement est lancé par le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat dans son dernier
rapport le giec adresse un message aux
dirigeants du monde entier il n'est pas
trop tard pour pour pour prendre des
mesures de réduction d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et qu'il y à une panne
un panoplie des missions de d'action
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre disponible aujourd'hui un
pas aller chercher des choses
dans tous les secteurs et dans tous les
domaines à coût raisonnable qui
permettent de limiter de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
ont d'ailleurs un potentiel pour 2,6
psion prise tout ensemble de diviser par
deux les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à l'horizon 2030 nous avons toutes
les clés en main nous disent les
chercheurs
réduire drastiquement la consommation
d'énergies fossiles au profit des
renouvelables
privilégiez les transports moins
polluants limiter l'étalement urbain
pour se déplacer - recycler plus de
matériaux dans l'industrie ou encore
développer la captation de co2 prise
tout ensemble ces solutions impliquent
un changement de modèle économique
ce rapport vous propose un bouquet de
solutions qu'il faudra mettre en oeuvre
toutes ensemble parce qu'en fait on est
dans un système complexe où tout est
interconnecté je vais prendre un exemple
si on parle de déployer le véhicule
électrique parce que ça permettrait de
réduire les émissions liées au transport
on ne vous donne pas une indication très
précise il faut aller jusqu'à nous dire
de quelle façon vous produisez votre
électricité si vous utilisez 100% de
chabrouh charbon pour produire notre
électricité
ne roulait pas dans un véhicule
électrique cette transformation
coûterait quelques points de pib mais le
prix de l'inaction serait bien plus
élevée prévient le giec d'après les
chercheurs au rythme actuel de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
réchauffement climatique dépassera les 3
degrés en 2100
le climat oublié de cette campagne
présidentielle voilà le thème de notre
débat avec maria eugenia ça d'un bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maître de
conférences en sciences économiques à
paris saclay spécialiste en énergie et
environnement hervé le treut bonsoir
achats et avenue climatologue membre de
l'académie des des sciences j'accueille
également frédéric dans les bons soirs
cette journaliste spécialisé questions
d'environnement talent auteur de
rencontres avec des écolos remarquable
c'est publié chez delachaux et nier ce
lait on a également avec nous en duplex
yannick servant bonsoir vous est le
cofondateur de la convention des
entreprises pour le climat bienvenue à
vous et matthieu croissandeau est resté
à mes côtés peut-être une première
réaction à ce rapport du giec maria
eugenia sanaa alors on vient de voir le
reportage mais qu'est ce que vous avez
appris quelque chose qu'est ce qui nous
dit de nouveau ce rapport final en fait
le rapport il fait il regarde un
ensemble des solutions possibles ça que
je trouve assez intéressant on sait que
je retiens c'est justement le moment
donc c'est dans un moment de tension où
justement on a des sauts problématiques
qui sont de quelque sorte alignés donc
on a le problème d un conflit avec notre
fournisseur de sources fossiles en ce
moment on a le problème de
l'indépendance énergétique européenne et
on a le problème de réchauffement
climatique une seule solution pour un
problème la substitution des ces sources
fossiles par des sources renouvelables
et ses rapports il est comme on
discutait tout à l'heure alors que
c'était aux discussions en coulisses
alors j'aime bien que les discussions
police vient sur le plateau dites nous
donc il ya plein de solutions qui sont
déjà dans les technologies existantes il
faut juste les déployer bien évidemment
c'est pas si simple mais on a les
coudées solaire à la diminuer des camps
des 45 % des parents 85 12 ans dès 2010
à 2019 la même chose avec les batteries
55% pour l'éolien
on a véritablement des solutions avec
des dites des technologies disponibles
et on pourrait à la fois à ceux situés
notamment le gaz russe qui est en
débat en ces moments par des sources qui
est ne céderait à tenir notre engagement
thématiques alors effectivement on peut
parler d'une opportunité à saisir ce que
ce que j'ai bien compris et hervé le
truc
cette urgence climatique elle est connue
depuis depuis plusieurs années le logica
publié de nombreux rapports là c'est le
second rapport 2ème rapport en un mois
qu'un peu plus d'un mois et sk
finalement est ce qu'on n'est pas face
une sorte de banalisation voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est est-ce que c'est pas
un risque dans la communication du du
siècle je moi je
j'adhère à l'importance de ce qui est
dit par les scientifiques du giec depuis
des années mais là notamment cette
campagne présidentielle ça n'a pas
imprimé oui cela n'imprime pas parce
qu'en fait on a effectivement la totale
le sentiment de répéter les mêmes choses
maintenant répète pas les mêmes choses
de les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
continuent de croître donc on est face à
un problème qui au contraire devient
chaque fois un peu plus difficile chaque
fois un peu plus important à considérer
et on ne peut certainement pas dire que
les choses se sont sont les mêmes les
halls annales le problème auquel on est
confronté est un problème qui est
toujours un problème croissant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui sont alors je prends deux
chiffres la question ceux d'avant le coc
vide mais ça s'est remis à peu près en
place depuis quelques temps on émet
chaque année quatre fois plus de co2
dans l'atmosphère que on le faisait dans
les années 60 et c'est des choses qui se
cumulent qui se cumulent au fil du temps
parce que les gaz à effet de serre qu'on
les met dans l'atmosphère reste présent
donc on n'est pas du tout dans un
problème aujourd'hui quand c'est
résoudre complètement part bien sûr il
ya des tas de solutions qui vont aider
mais ces solutions vont aider f pour le
moment elles ne permettent pas de
résoudre le problème le problème est un
problème qui reste posée de manière
extrêmement forte et bien sûr c'est pour
ça qu'on a besoin d'un panorama large de
solutions parce qu'autrement sans pourra
pas s'en sortir mais l'idée qu'on est
face à quelque chose qui serait une
répétition de ce qu'on a connu ça c'est
une idée complètement fausse alors il ya
un problème pour la faire passer mais
c'est une idée qui est très dangereuse
même il ya une vous nous dites ya une
aggravation ya quand même une petite
amélioration si on regarde les deux
dernières décennies c'est à dire que
l'augmentation des gaz à effet de serre
est un peu moins forte entre 2010 et
2019 que entre
2001 et 2010 et ça si j'ai bien compris
le râle le rapport du giec oui mais
enfin il est en même temps il faut
effectivement
faudrait arriver à une neutralité 012
est jeune et on est très très loin on en
est très loin dans steam afrique dans
les camps vous quand vous lisez ce
nouveau rapport du giec comment vous
réagissez vous dit ce qui était
intéressant de reportage il ya des
propositions il y à des leviers à
activer mais cette idée de il faut tout
acte iv ensemble en fait c'est peut-être
ça ce qu'il faut ce qu'on doit retenir
de ce rapport ben oui on en est là alors
effectivement il ya les choses avancent
comme le dit hervé le problème le
problème s'aggrave mais sur les
solutions proposées ça fait 30 ans qu'on
les connaît trente ans et c'est un peu
désabusé en moins en parler en fac des
gens 92 mon prendre d'écologie serge
frontier non plus là nous en parlait
déjà de ces du réchauffement climatique
et de l'inévitable réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
de l'inévitable usage moindre des
combustibles fossiles etc on se posait
déjà la question c'était ma formation
d'ingénierie colloque comment
dimensionne de un champ d'éoliennes
comment on met des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur un toit c'est en 92
cette affaire-là alors ce rapport a au
moins le mérite de tout mettre ensemble
de ne pas opposer les solutions il
assiste à la fois par exemple en fait
c'est un grand mantra si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi sur le stockage du
carbone la récupération du carbone dans
l'atmosphère et en même par des moyens
industriels et par des moyens naturels
il insiste beaucoup là dessus
en fait il faut lire une page c'est la
page 50 c'est le foot notre 69 voilà je
vous la montre elle tout résumé sur un
graphique c'est les solutions selon
leurs coûts au carbone éviter selon leur
faisabilité par rapport aux technologies
actuelles
et va aider l'agriculture à maintenir
ses prairies donc derrière l'élevage
avoir des seins seulement différends
autrement dit j'en ai déjà parlé sur ce
plateau avoir une agriculture qui
travaille ses sols avec beaucoup de
matière organique dont beaucoup de
fertilité parce que cette fertilité va
absorber du carbone ça fait partie des
solutions comme aiment ça en avoir parlé
ici aussi maintenir les tourbières
maintenir les zones humides parce que
c'est le stock de carbone tout en
développant des technologies qui
n'existe pas encore pour absorber des
cannes c'est intéressant parce que vous
ne parlez vous interrompez vous mettez
ça prioritairement en avant plus que la
question dont vous parliez des énergies
fossiles parce que intuitivement se dit
le premier leviers à activer et qu'on
est en train de baisser celui là c'est
les deux en même temps facile et de même
temps c'est à la fois absorbé au maximum
et puis en même temps produire autrement
et le rapport a quand même une nouveauté
par rapport à port précédent qui
insistait lourdement sur le nucléaire là
il insiste moins en estimant que le
solaire et
et le fauteuil pendant le solaire et
l'éolien ont la plus grande capacité à
nous permettre de moins émettre de co2
pour un coût moindre mais avec une marge
d'erreur importante et le nucléaire a
une marge d'erreur parce qu'il est plus
prévisible plus faible mais par contre
son coup il est astronomique par rapport
quand vous allez d'une marge d'erreur
c'est quoi c'est l'efficacité le fait de
pouvoir l'utiliser non c'est la marée on
dire mais le mathematica chlorite se
permettre de dire que par exemple sur
l'énergie solaire on peut économiser
entre 2 et 4 milliards de tonnes de
carbone ok la marche de manoeuvre va
jusqu'à 6 c les raisons de votre
éducation parce que j'avais pas bien
compris donc peut-être qu'une partie de
nos téléspectateurs
aussi je vais donner la parole à yannick
servant cette convention des entreprises
pour le climat c'est plus de 150
dirigeants et dirigeantes qui se
réunissent régulièrement et des sessions
de de travail vous êtes entouré
d'experts et est ce qu'on retient c'est
que ses dirigeants de ses dirigeants ils
sont en train de transformer le modèle
économique de leur entreprise
on s'est rencontrés dans d'autres
émissions en l'occurrence urbis park
après la première session en septembre
les participants avaient parlé de
claques climatique qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya eu une prise de conscience
de l'urgence à ce moment là
complètement et quand on parle de
claques climatique ce qui est ce qu'il
est intéressant c'est elle a lieu et
elle est productive quand on allie le
quelque chose d'assez iconoclaste que
dans l'umd de l'entreprise le cerveau et
le coeur parce que et voir moi ce que ça
nous parce que ça nous inspire de voir
les rapports qui sortiront team
sortirait participants ce que ça leur
inspire sais c'est que quand on parle de
lutter contre le changement climatique
il a une vision assez technocratique du
truc à chaque fois qu'un rapport du giec
sort c'est très chiffré ses tricks
antilles et en fait c'est plus une
question de lutter contre nous mêmes
plutôt que de lutter contre le
changement climatique a quelque chose de
très les internes et avec la session 1
de la cec comme las la session 1 de la
convention citoyenne
avant a en outre insisté vraiment aidé
ces deux d'avoir à disposition toute la
matière la compréhension scientifique et
prendre le temps de l'intégrer
2 le vif dans les tripes il ya un
exercice c'est intéressant qu'on a
proposé aux participants c'était deux
ayant tous ayant assisté à tous à
décrire ce qu'on a eu une lettre au
tulle lettre à l'enfant du futur que ce
soit leurs enfants eux l'enfant que
peut-être ils s'imaginent avoir et c'est
un exercice extrêmement poignant en fait
les dirigeants la façade rationnelle un
conomique est tombée on est vraiment
allé sur le coeur et c'est là ça va
vraiment me projeter dans le elle que
joie des images de manifestations et
d'enfants ont beaucoup de participants
s'est t'il eu la force il convainc cct
lançant non mais papa maman en gros
qu'est ce que je fous ça c'est l'émotion
mais après il ya l'action j'aurais
oublie rapidement qu'il ya quand je
disais modèle économique en train
d'évoluer sais c'est pas c'est pas juste
une formule ou quoi bien sûr ça c'est la
session 1 de la cec c'était ça la
prochaine session pour nous ça sera la
cinquième session à à lyon et après la
première session qui était comprendre et
se laisser pénétrer par un sujet la
question c'est ok comment seront en
action deuxième session c'était comment
je transforme mon business model comment
j'imagine passer d'une économie
extractives à une économie contributive
puis régénérative ensuite comment je
repense la finance la comptabilité
qu'est-ce qu'on compte quand on compte
autre chose que des euros comment on
nous dise parce que le métier du
dirigeant même temps l'entreprise on
optimise avec des feuilles excel par
rapport à d europa faut regarder autre
chose la session 4 c'était l'innovation
le marketing le rapport aux progrès la
session 5 ça sera sur le leadership de
transition en pleine conscience du fait
que par rapport aux murs
environnementale pas que climatiques
qu'on a en face de nous et certains pans
de l'économie certains métiers qui ne
sont juste pas compatible et ça c'est
pas grave c'est une question de
réinvention des métiers des modèles et
ça me met en tension parce que c'est de
l'inconnu les jours donnait la parole
tout à l'heure il ya un hic servent en
mai notamment parce que vous publiez une
tribune à paraître demain dans dans
ouest france sur la question de la de la
connaissance la formation même des
décideurs pas seulement les politiques
en france ce sera un des thèmes de notre
débat tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
entendre maintenant le donner la parole
aux coprésidents d'un des groupes de
travail du giec qui s'appelle james qui
il parle de l'urgence à agir maintenant
faute de quoi il deviendra impossible de
limiter à 1,5 degrés la hausse moyenne
des températures sur la planète on les
écoute
le changement climatique est le résultat
de plusieurs siècles l'utilisation non
durable de l'énergie des sols des modes
de consommation et de production
ce rapport a permis de montrer qu'en
agissant maintenant nous pouvons nous
diriger vers un monde plus juste et plus
vivable
en résumé nous savons ce qu'il faut
faire nous savons comment le faire et il
ne tient qu'à nous d'agir santos et
l'autre peut-être il faut rappeler ce
que ça change quoi d'être au delà des
indiens 5 degrés de plus en moyenne sur
la planète par rapport au jour d'hui oui
lalinde bourse ça va être très difficile
de rester sous cette barre on y arrivera
sans doute pas à quoi
il faut il faut il faut prendre des
objectifs je me rappelle
l'époque de
des années 68 c'était de soyons soyons
résonne soyons raisonnables demandons
l'impossible voilà je pense qu'on en est
là on est un petit peu là aujourd'hui et
c'est quand même aussi une manière
d'essayer de réfléchir rapport à ces
problèmes là mais les caisses que ça
change si on est à + 2 degrés plus de
ennemi qu'est ce que ça change en fait
souvent c'est très difficile d'arriver à
convaincre les gens que ce sont des
changements qui sont importants je pense
que la meilleure analogie qu'on peut
avoir c'est celle du corps humain
finalement quand on regarde ce qu'on a
notre température à new bell balle
passée de d'un degré de plus à un autre
degré de plus ça ça compte beaucoup on a
aussi un système le système climatique
et réguler port par un peu les mêmes
phénomènes finalement que ceux de que
ceux du corps humain donc quand on a 35
39 5 de fièvre voilà donc on est
vraiment dans une situation aujourd'hui
où ces qui paraît petit et était très
important et on le voit aussi parce
qu'on a eu un système climatique qui a
été très
extraordinairement réguler pendant 2 sur
la paix l'holocène c'est à dire les deux
les 12 millions d'années qui sont qui
sont
derrière nous donc en fait on est face à
quelque chose qui représente une perte
de
2 on
on est en train de créer un différentiel
qui paraît pas que de toute réforme qui
est qui effectivement un modifie tout
magnifie tout suivant majeur je voudrais
qu'on revienne sur les solutions les
actions proposées évoquée par le giec et
notamment alors là on va vraiment parler
des énergies et de la question du
nucléaire et vous propose
de lire ce que l'un de nos candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
disait sur twitter alerte hashtag giec
les décisions que nous prenons
maintenant peuvent garantir un avenir
vivable il reste trois ans pour
bifurquer en misant sur les énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire commencera à
être hors service la mission climat des
10 et 24 avril est tracée bon voilà il
est vraiment dans sa campagne
présidentielle mais c'est intéressant
sur la question du nucléaire jours et
vous entendre maria eugenia sanaa parce
que est ce qu'on peut se passer du
nucléaire pour essayer de réduire de
l'imiter
l'impact de notre impact carbone et donc
se passer le plus vite possible des
énergies fossiles est ce qu'on peut se
passer du nucléaire
la réponse donnée par le par le rapport
c'est que non effectivement parmi les
technologies proposées comme des
solutions il y a le nucléaire et comme
on dit c'est tout à l'heure et justement
parce que l'énergie donc les
renouvelables on peut glisser sur
beaucoup de renouvelables mais il nous
faut des scénarii que ce soit pas
intermittente donc les renouvelables et
son lac en élevant on a souvent on a du
soleil on avait sont aussi des énergies
qui sont là doutant et le nucléaire à 7
cette capacité et non du coup c'est une
solution plutôt qu'un problème après il
posé ce problème mais pour le
réchauffement climatique effectivement
le nucléaire c'est une solution et on ne
va pas s'en passer mathieu pour le coup
une fois n'est pas coutume je ne suis
pas tout à fait en accord et que ce ce
titre du climat où il l'est tandis que
le nucléaire ça a été un débat de la
campagne c'est vrai ça a été abordée n'a
été abordé il a tué parce que parce que
c'est l'état derrière parce que c'est la
puissance parce qu'il ya l'armée en tout
cas médiatiquement politiquement des
candidats se sont prononcés pour ou
contre on va parler les éoliennes donc
les énergies nouvelles à travers le prix
sur les éoliennes ça a été un débat de
la campagne elle ne peut aller contre
exe mort et qu'on te dise que c'est
moche le débat est dépassé un peu ces
questions en bas de gamme et on en a
discuté des éoliennes oui ce que ce qui
est passée totalement sur les radars
sont les rapports du giec en revanche ça
ça oui tout à fait mais après moi je
trouve que que la phrase qu'elle
prononce et yannick servant elle est
assez juste au fond c'est il faut lutter
contre nous mêmes mais est d'une
certaine façon si on en a pas non plus
tellement parlé à la campagne c'est que
les français sont aussi paradoxaux
vis-à-vis de ces questions-là des deux
candidats que soit yannick jadot jean
luc mélenchon qu'on peut aimer ou
détester second temps présent mais en
quoi un projet de transition ou
bifurcation écologique qui est assez
complet qui a été saluée comme telle par
différentes associations indépendantes
yannick jadot c'est pas un candidat qui
a les faveurs de l'opinion parce que
l'opinion publique elle est prête à
voter pour des écolos quand il faut
gérer ries et refaire un espace vert
j'exagère un peu mais quand il faut leur
confier destin national eh ben on est on
est pas là c'est le paradoxe des
français qui sont un peu écolo parce
qu'ils déclarent tous très sensibilisés
au climat et c'est une bonne chose mais
quand il s'agit de passer à l'action
voilà il ya plus il ya plus grand boubou
bien intervenir oui parce que je pense
que là on parle du climat de
une situation qui pour moi être doit
être série un petit peu on a besoin
d'agir rapidement et on a une
problématique est celle du climat
présent à court terme pour terme ça peut
être quelques quelques années et puis on
a un système climatique qui est
qui et qui engage le futur sur des
périodes extrêmement longue on est en
train de faire aujourd'hui c'est
d'engager le futur manière un peu
silencieuse sans qu'on s'en rende compte
sur l'épaule sur des périodes qui sont
extrêmement lors d'it extrême dents
longues c'est quoi ces plusieurs
décennies c'est plusieurs siècles c'est
ça peut aller à plusieurs siècles oui
effectivement donc on est en train de
créer des choses qui sont irréversibles
très fortement on voit le cette
irréversibilité qui se manifeste par
exemple dans les océans aujourd'hui donc
tout ce qui se passe là ça demande une
réflexion qui est un peu différente on
doit commencer essayez de faire
fonctionner les choses aujourd'hui parce
que c'est là qu'on est mais on peut pas
oublier qu'on est aussi en train de me
faire fonctionner un système dont on ne
sait pas ce qu'il va nous donner comme
résultat dont futur d'une certaine façon
par exemple c'est ça qui devrait être le
thème je t'aime majeur d'une campagne
présidentielle parce que c'est le moment
vas-y des projets politiques pour
longtemps c'est aussi une vision qu'on
attend d'un président ou une présidente
alors après sans cracher dans la soupe
mais aussi la hiérarchie l'info qui fait
comme un politique est au dessus
l'écologie est en dessous et qu'un homme
politique ne peut être interviewé par un
journaliste politique moi je rêve de les
interviewer tous un candidat à la
présidentielle donc ils sont jamais
confrontés aux questions si ce n'est aux
questions banales basique on ramène tout
l'environnement aux éoliennes au
nucléaire et un débat manichéen qui
n'existe pas ailleurs qu'à paris /
nucléaire ou
hulu éoliennes c'est un peu d'huile
d'olive reuber mac ou pc on oppose
systématiquement les deux chacun est
obligé de se positionner ça n'a aucun
sens n'a aucun sens d'autant plus qu'en
local
les écolos qui font pas rêver à
l'échelle nationale parce qu'il raconte
ans il parle pas aux gens il n'ya pas de
récit qui vient substituer aux quasiment
récit judéo-chrétien de la fin en fait
ils parlent que de catastrophe mais au
niveau local les écolos sont efficaces
et au niveau local c'est l'objet de mon
bouquin et d'un documentaire que j'ai
fait derrière enfin depuis des échos
laurent un câble ouais c'est des écoles
qui sont pas écolo cdh et mr ces déchets
d'entreprise et des associatifs par
exemple ce chef d'entreprise de brioude
ki moon qui ne comprenait rien à la
complexité réglementaire pour obtenir
une autorisation et les subventions pour
mettre des panneaux solaires au dessus
de son entreprise il les a payés même
résultat son entreprise non seulement
ils neutre en électricité il produit sa
propre électricité qu'il va revendre sur
le marché et depuis ce chef d'entreprise
est devenu adjoint au maire de la bonne
ville de brioude donc ils commencent à
avoir un impact sur ses citoyens et des
cas comme ça il y en a plein je cite
également la toute petite ville dont
elle lui dit dans le cantal qui a réussi
l'exploit malgré sa très faible densité
de population de développer un réseau de
chaleur au bois avec du bois local tout
a été fait localement en se passant des
subventions finalement ensuite l'état
est arrivé derrière pour dire on va vous
aider tout ça c'est du local et ça
commence à faire sans ça fait tellement
sens que lequel est cité quatre fois
dont le dans le rapport du giec c'est
par là que les choses il ya des servants
je reviens vers vous parce que vous vous
dites que c'est un poème de formation
de nos décideurs et on peut s'inclure
nous journalistes d'ailleurs indépendant
dans la liste comme vous disiez que les
gens disent politiques sont pas
suffisamment finalement informé ou
méconnaissent les vrais enjeux pour
poser les bonnes questions aux candidats
qu'est ce que vous voulez mettre en
place en termes de formation des
décideurs français
avant de répondre à ça pour rebondir sur
ce que c'est frédéric un instant cet
exercice d'interviewer les candidats ou
leurs représentants sur autre chose que
du cner versus renouvelables mais plus
ou comment ils projettent une économie
cela blanche on l'a fait quant à lui
sont disponibles sur notre site c'est
assez intéressant comme exercice
à ne pas renforcer dans notre conclusion
que la formation est essentielle la
formation broom sa veut dire mines
passer au minimum 20 heures pleines sur
votre sujet ne pas regarder que climat
énergie mais comprendre biodiversité
pollution déplétion de ressources et
surtout l'interaction entre toutes ces
choses là est encore plus important que
ça on dit formation
classiquement on peut dire la formation
sont ok je vais te
20h02 derrière vie c'est ce dont ma
chaise a écouté des présentations de
magistrales décembre en penser son
smartphone non information faut qu'elle
se vivent en sincérité et c'est là que
le pet le le plus beau le plus gros
challenge nous il finit on pense que il
y aura des vraies avancées quand
décideurs économiques et politiques
auront investi ce temps là pour
comprendre les enjeux et avoir
opéré le gel par lâcher prise pour
laisser descendre le celui de laisser
descendre l'urgence on dit que on n'a
que trois ans pour atteindre le pic
d'émissions
pardon pour la blague mais c'est chaud
donc je suis là
donc il faut aller vite on l'a bien
compris et propose un mario viraux qui
doit être juste là en coulisses de 2
nous rejoindrons soir marion va on va où
on est on est finalement aussi sur la
question de la place de ceux de ses
enjeux climatiques de ces enjeux de
biodiversité et des rapports du giec
dans cette campagne présidentielle il
faut dire qu'il ya eu la guerre en
ukraine ça a quand même fait évidemment
compliqué la donne effectivement
maladière en ukraine qui a commencé le
24 février février dernier bouleverse
tous les agendas y compris donc là j'en
donne climatique c'est bien simple le 28
février soit quatre jours après
l'invasion russe le giec publie le
deuxième volume de son nouveau rapport
un rapport qui passe alors complètement
à la trappe selon une étude réalisée par
la plateforme taga des entre le 28
février et le 11 mars et publié dans le
jdd la pression médiatique autour du
rapport du giec est estimée à 0,3 pour
cent contre 17% pour l'ukraine il faut
dire qu'à l'époque la sidération autour
de ce conflit et les déclarations
belliqueuses de vladimir poutine qui
brandit la menace nucléaire sont tels
que le climat n'est clairement plus une
priorité très vite les sanctions prises
à l'encontre de la russie vont accélérer
ce phénomène en particulier sur le volet
agricole avec un rétro pédalage tout
d'abord sur la stratégie agricole
européenne baptisée de la ferme à la
fourchette ce nouveau pacte vert
européen devait réduire d'ici à 2030 le
recours aux pesticides l'apport
d'engrais les européens devaient
également accroître de 10 % des surfaces
agricoles en jachère et de 25% la part
du bio mais la guerre a donc rebattu les
cartes l'ukraine et la russie sont allés
grenier du monde est désormais coupée de
ses deux marchés les européens
reviennent vers une logique
productiviste à pour garantir leur
souveraineté alimentaire et la
commission européenne est sommée de
revoir sa copie au vu des circonstances
impact on l'a déjà un peu ok c'est au
tour de l'énergie oui puisque je vous
redonne quelques chiffres la russie est
le premier partenaire énergétique de
l'europe qui importe 40% de gaz naturel
25% de pétrole et 40 % de charbon de
russie et conséquence avec le conflit de
nombreux pays sont donc en train de re
vous alors approvisionnements
énergétiques ainsi la bulgarie à
reporter la fermeture de ses centrales à
charbon et l'allemagne les a relancé le
charbon qui est de toutes les énergies
fossiles et la plus polluante la semaine
dernière deux responsables de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie étaient
entendus au sénat ils ont détaillé leurs
plans pour réduire à court terme d'un
tiers cette dépendance à la russie et à
leurs yeux il est pour le moment
compliqué d'aller plus loin si l'on veut
rester dans une logique de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
puisque ce coupé complètement du gaz
russe reviendrait à augmenter encore
plus notre dépendance aux autres
énergies fossiles et écouter justement
ce que disait devant les sénateurs team
bulls qui est le chef économique en
charge de l'énergie a les yeux
lorsqu'ils concernent maintenant les
répercussions sur les ges gaz à effet de
serre l'une des options possibles c'est
qu'il y aura peut être une augmentation
à court terme des gaz à effet de serre
léger us car peut-être que les citoyens
utiliseront un peu plus de charbon comme
moyen compensation au gaz mais il sera
possible de voir peut-être une
accélération
des efforts de décarbonation à moyen
terme a longtemps qu'une augmentation
des gaz à effet de serre à kout à court
terme mais pas forcément à moyen terme
cela signifie que le kid le climat peut
peut-être sortir gagnant de cette crise
en obligeant les pays européens à
accélérer leur transition énergétique et
aussi à s'orienter vers plus de sobriété
une idée qui commence à faire son chemin
on se rappellera d'ailleurs que le début
de la semaine a commencé par un appel de
rte au français à modérer leur
consommation électrique fiable merci
marion pour pour cette intervention
maria eugenia sanaa sur le peut-être sur
le volet agricole c'est intéressant
parce que là aussi on parle de temps
long passé ça rend pessimiste de voir
que l'union européenne est en train de
changer de pied sur 7 sur cette doctrine
sur formes toutes ses formes tout force
et ça j'étais en train d'inverser de la
ferme à la fourchette sur les jachères
comment vous interpréter ce changement
de pied mais l'union européenne il ya
urgence il va falloir on veut éviter les
émeutes de la faim enfin on a bien
compris tout tout l'argumentaire de
certains mais est ce que le risque c'est
que ça prenne trop de temps ensuite pour
refaire le chemin arrière voilà est-ce
que je le fais bien comprendre oui oui
en fait en économie rona c'est quoi
cette relation que l'on appelle des
l'inconsistance dynamique c'est-à-dire
si on prend une décision aujourd'hui et
n'est pas cohérente avec sa com' à faire
demain ça entraîne un coût plus élevé
c'est pour ça que sa fraîcheur ça coûte
plus cher encore simplement parce que l
on est en trajectoire comme ça on a vu
deux dans le rapport du giec en regard
des trajectoires et ses trajectoires on
les fait par rapport au coût n'est pas
agir vis à vis au bénéfice d agir
maintenant et donc ça coûte plus cher
dès faire quelque chose parce qu'après
le fort de revenir en arrière et encore
que c'est plus difficile à faire et du
coup ils entraînent des coûts encore
plus donc vous êtes en train de nous
dire que si on fait marche arrière sur
la politique agricole on va le payer on
va le payer après quoi c'est exactement
donc seraient tous les politiques
d'ailleurs la même chose pour l'énergie
si jamais chose parce que on a une une
sonné la situation
difficile vis-à-vis des certains
aliments notamment ont fait marche
arrière ça sert à beaucoup plus coûteux
des revenir sur la trajectoire donc ce
n'est pas une très bonne idée
l eridan et vous avez écrit beaucoup
travaillé sur la question de notre
indépendance alimentaire notre modèle
économique est ce qui est à l'oeuvre là
depuis depuis quelques semaines depuis
le début de cette guerre en ukraine est
ce que il ya effectivement une urgence
qu'on il faut trouver une solution ou
est-ce qu'il ya finalement les lots bild
du vieux modèle de la pac qui invite
dans sa tombe bien j'ai fait un pin
enquête pour marianne la semaine
dernière là dessus non
non on peut effectivement retourner des
jachères pour faire des cultures mais ce
ne sera pas cette année ce sera l'an
prochain on peut le faire si c'est du
très court terme c'est derrière on fait
une culture et ensuite on laisse à
nouveau l'âge est là je vais faire
s'installer il ya quand même un un sens
de l'histoire image un peu galvaudé à
l'échelle de l'europe où l'europe est en
train de ressortir un texte très
technique s'appelle à direct qui sol je
fais très court l'europe est en train de
réfléchir à asseoir sa politique
agricole à la qualité de ses sols la
qualité de ses sols qui si elle atteint
un certain niveau devient devient un
puits de carbone permet au sol est très
plat carbone ce que je disais tout à
l'heure ce que signale le rapport du
giec c'est à dire on privilégie une
agriculture de conservation des sols qui
travaillent peu les seuls qui laisse les
sols couverts en permanence entre les
cultures qui développe les prairies et
qui recrée 7 polyculture élevage on
avait un peu oublié donc la tendance
allait plutôt à l'agroécologie qui a
faut jamais oublier que
korichi ici si j'ai tort je crois que 25
%
25 % des émissions de carbone sont ré
absorbée par les prairies 25% c'est les
forêts le reste c'est les océans donc la
politique agricole 1 re aura un impact
immédiat fin immédiate à moyen terme
dont vous dit que la direction prise est
la bonne oui par l'europe et on peut
quoi on peut s'offrir quatre ans peu
déliées de voilà c'est ça de façon à
certines évitons répondre à l'urgence
quoi il faut il faut compenser en non
seulement les pertes de cette année de
l'ukraine et de la russie mais si demain
les ukrainiens peuvent pas faire leur
semis de blé on aura une mévente
on aura une perte de production nette
l'an prochain qu'il faudra compenser
d'une façon ou d'une autre donc on est
obligé de le faire
les solutions qui sont évoqués par le
giec sont des solutions de deux temps
long c'est ce que vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure même de temps très long et une
campagne présidentielle c'est aussi un
homo idéal pour prendre des décisions
tout ces décisions qui engagent notre
avenir commun premier du nucléaire
mathieu c'est quand même majeurs le
modèle d'agriculture on vient de
l'évoquer chez par la construction des
bâtiments là aussi c'est majeur il faut
il faut changer de modèle en y intégrant
l'économie ce qu'on appelle l'économie
circulaire l'électrification des
transports ok mais avec quelles sources
pour produire l'énergie tout ça c'est
majeur et malgré tout je reste là dessus
sur le sur la question d'un modèle
général moi j'ai le sentiment que ça a
été très peu abordée ou pas suffisamment
abordé je crois qu'on est face à un
problème qui est avant tout un problème
du complexe je me disais tout à l'heure
qu'on est face à des situations et des
enjeux qu'on peut qu'on compte qu'on
doit liés les uns aux autres on est on
est dans un système qui est qui
complique est vraiment un système malkin
qui est complexe et je crois que ça
demande effectivement une
une capacité à un
haut niveau du collectif de raisonner de
réfléchir de retrouver d une manière de
lier ces problèmes là qu'ils soient
partagés au niveau de la population je
crois qu'aujourd'hui un manque énorme à
ce niveau là on est face à un problème
qui objectivement est un des problèmes
les plus compliquées auxquelles on a été
confronté depuis ces deux dernières
années et on y va sans beaucoup de
réflexions en fait beaucoup de
réflexions partagées je crois que là il
ya un enjeu qui est un enjeu majeur et
effectivement c'est un enjeu qu'on
aurait on devrait traiter aussi effect
peut-être même effectivement
très fortement au moment des d'un moment
comme les élections que qui sont nés
étaient des nôtres mais il ya là un
manque je pense extrêmement en étant on
met en place des voitures électriques
bon très bien ça pour la court terme ça
va certainement marchés qui ont plus
tard qu'est ce qui va se passer et ce
qu'on fera l'électricité comment la
mettra en place tous ces moments là sont
des éléments on va trouver des matériaux
les terrains pour produire les batteries
voilà donc tous ces éléments là ne sont
pas discuté de manière suffisante je
pense aujourd'hui et je persiste à dire
mathieu mais que je vais vous donner un
autre chiffre parce que marion évoqué le
temps d'antenne c'est vraiment
intéressant nos confrères de d'arrêt sur
image qu'ont publié ça ce 6 avril entre
donc le lundi 4 6 heures du matin et le
mardi 5 avril 17h ils ont ils ont
calculé et donc le verdict at 6 heures
du matin c'est la publication de ce
nouveau rapport du giec c'est assez
vertigineux entre 0 et 0,5 pour cent et
1,9 pour cent du temps d'antenne des jt
des chaînes privées 6 5% du temps
d'antenne des jt sur france 2 et si on
regarde là une radio france info en
l'occurrence 5% du temps d'antenne sur
sur france info bon là ou alors d'accord
il rire en ukraine d'accord bon mais
c'est quand même tout tout tout tout
petit mais société journaux de 20 heures
alors je fais confiance à arrêt sur
image via 1 6% des temps d'antenne du jt
de france 2 c'est beaucoup moins sur les
chaînes privées et 0,1 je pense qu'il ya
des sujets je pense à une chaîne
concurrente de france 2 qui avait au 20
heures un sujet qui n'était pas 0,6 pour
cent des d35 de la la c'est sûr
en fait on se rejoint cinq mois je je
pense que il ya eu des débats sur des
mesures un qui était dans les différents
programmes il n'y a pas eu de débat sur
les projets ou sur d'évasion ou sur une
vision globale et là où elle vous avez
entièrement raison on n'a pas eu ce
grand débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait à
l'échelle d'un demi siècle ou d'un
siècle parce que ça paraît hors cadre et
hors sol si j'ose dire on les paye
hommes politiques aujourd'hui qui
résonne quand même en terme d'électorat
du qui va voter pour moi et si je
propose un truc qui sera bon pour notre
siècle eh ben je serai pas élus par les
gens dedans un siècle en gros je
caricature mais c'est à peu près ça et
au delà de ça c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
eu ce se passe qui a pas eu de débat
dans cette campagne et a pas eu de
vision n'est pas une projet est donc ça
on l'a été a commenté la mesure des uns
et des autres y aurait ce qu'elles sont
bonnes pas bonne on l'a fait j'ai parlé
détruire ce que c'est bon pas bon mais
voilà il n'ya pas y'a pas eu ce ce grand
rassemblement démocratique autour de 2,7
à venir qu'il faut qu'il faut discuter
il y en a un qui pouvait porter ça c'est
yannick jadot est certainement mieux
informé que les autres l'ancien
directeur des campagnes de greenpeace
france on écoute le candidat europe
écologie verts
je suis le seul parce que lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique
c'est penser notre survie c'est penser
notre avenir c'est sauver notre avenir
celui nos enfants donc pour moi c'est au
coeur de toutes les politiques publiques
et est ce que dit le rapport du giec
c'est tout gagner la bataille du climat
et en gagnant la bataille du climat on
ne sauve pas simplement notre avenir on
ne crée pas simplement un avenir pour
nos enfants un peu plus bienveillants on
crée de l'emploi
alors c'est très facile à dire depuis
mon fauteuil d'observateurs bien
tranquille mais c'est quand même une
occasion manquée qui semble assez
immense pour java c'est habituel chez
les écolos à une faune crac et les
occasions il transforme en plomb l'orc
est devant mais il suffit d'écouter il a
dit sur vie sauve et comment voulez vous
adhérez un discours vous dit sur vies
sauvées pourquoi ne pas simplement dire
que l'écologie c'est une nouvelle façon
de faire la politique que l'écologie
c'est faire l'aménagement du territoire
par exemple et quand on fait
l'aménagement du territoire on pense à
l'approvisionnement des villes on pense
à la politique du logement parce que si
les gens utilisent leur véhicule diesel
qui polluent c'est parce qu'ils habitent
ou 1,6 habitent loin c'est aussi à cause
du prix du foncier ciprelli foncier est
aussi élevées c'est parce qu'il est pas
régulé contrairement aux pays d'europe
du nord donc on interroge en fait le
fondement de la société on interroge la
gouvernance sur les problèmes de l'eau
par exemple la gouvernance actuelle est
très bon enfant c'est une bouffée
renonce pyramide keramidas pardon c'est
une gouvernance à l'échelle locale avec
des élus locaux qui décident pour l'eau
qui passe chez eux ça devrait être un
mode de gouvernance pour la bourre pour
la biomasse par exemple pour l'énergie à
l'échelle d'un territoire pourquoi de
vendanger centralisant vraiment quoi
avec le contrôle 8 à ce que veut dire
par là c'est que l'écologie ça devrait
être transversale que l'église est une
façon de faire de la politique de façon
transverse et de l'aménagement du
territoire est-ce qu'on l'entend chez
jadot non hélas qui parle des gens donc
un mot de conclusion là dessus oui moi
je pense qu'elles portent unités manqué
c'est parce que dans le contexte actuel
et et on à la fin du mois et la fin du
monde alignés parce que le problème
justement des de pouvoir payer la
facture électrique que la facture du gaz
etc donc c'est opportunité c'est une
grande opportunité manquée parce que
elle pourrait justement expliqué comment
dans cette logique de planification
écologique on pourrait
aider le pouvoir d'achat est en montée
l'homme l'emploi et justement les
les métiers liés à donc réévaluer ses
tout à l'ensemble des métiers c'est une
opportunité manquée sans doute merci
beaucoup à tous désolé j'ai pas le temps
de vous redonner la parole j'en suis
vraiment navré avec le truc mais merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat
fait d'un jeu rappelle le titre
rapidement d'autres lives rencontre avec
des écolos remarquable c'est publié chez
delachaux est signé ce lait est bien un
cerveau on va on lira votre tribune
c'est dans ouest-france publication
demain appel à la formation de nos
décideurs
et je trouve que c'est une très bonne
idée merci à tous encore une fois